ognuno di noi dentro di sé Ha una luce
Il problema è trovarla
alimentarla e
lasciarle risplendere
ho un fratello vuol dire che se ne frega
No è importante Filippo 10 anni più
giorni di me ingegnere nessuno è
perfetto Ecco Filippo mi ha sempre
sfidato in tutto vedete maschietto lui
maschietto io voi sapete che i maschi
fanno a gara in tutto No per esempio
arriviamo a casa da amici con in testa
un cappellino un berretto di New York
Yankees siamo capaci togliendoci
ritirandolo se per caso va incastrarsi
fra due libri Ecco siamo capaci di
passarla serata a tirare il cappellino
nel tentativo di incastrarlo Fra quei
libri Dio Qualcuno ci Salvi donne
ragazze Dateci una mano Siamo siamo
malati Ma questa cosa questa
caratteristica di noi maschietti mi ha
cambiato la vita il nostro sfidarci il
nostro metterci continuamente in
competizione vedete il fratello
all'epoca della storia che sto per
raccontare aveva dieci anni io 20
ovviamente più grande
Ponzi ponzi po po po
dicevo a far botte oggi mi diverto meno
vincevo giocare ping pong vincevo alla
corsa vincevo in tutto giocare a calcio
Ecco anche se il calcio l'odio ma
vincevo anche a quello bene un giorno
arrivo a casa da una vacanza con i miei
genitori con un piccolo Diablo Avete
presente quell'attrezzo di giocoleria la
clessidra bacchette filo faceva poca
roba lanciata presa frustata poca roba
ma era più bravo di me questa cosa non
poteva essere
sono diventato giocoliere per senso di
rivalsa nei confronti di mio fratello
ora la cosa poi nasce cosa Ovviamente io
ho continuato lui ha smesso si è messa a
fare altro io invece no questa cosa l'ho
continuata ad alimentare perché vedete
poi ha cominciato a pagarmi ho capito
che se una cosa ti piace e ti pagano per
farla ti piace di più farla Ecco questa
cosa ve la lascio ve la regalo se volete
ma questa cosa a me mi sembra una
motivazione Ecco ho cominciato con La
Gavetta Come fanno in tanti la mia
Gavetta è stata le feste di compleanno
attenti fare feste di compleanno con
davanti 20
potenziali assassini di 8 anni Ecco
è veramente una Gavetta quella un teatro
come questo No pieno di gente questo non
mi spaventa mentre invece avere davanti
loro quella è una vera Gavetta Gavetta
che ha segnato anche l'altro mio lavoro
io faccio l'insegnante un giorno entro
in classe una delle primissime supplenze
che ho fatto e davanti a me una
ragazzina che alza le mani fa prof Beh
si chiamava Dimmi lei è stato il mio
regalo di compleanno
ma dopo mi ha portato la foto io con le
braccia otto anni e la parrucca Insomma
Va bene va bene fare il giocoliere ma
permesso di mantenermi agli studi mi
sono praticamente pagato l'università
feste di compleanno prima poi sono
passato a fare altro ovviamente sono
passato a fare i teatri le feste di
piazza e poi la divulgazione ma tutte
cominciato sfidando mio fratello
ora c'è un problema come fai a diventare
giocoliere come fai a all'epoca io ho 46
anni figlia per 6 col resto di 4 Ecco
all'epoca non c'erano scuole di
giocoleria a Bologna non ce n'erano non
c'erano corsi associazioni non c'era
niente non c'era internet Sì esatto il
Giurassico e quindi come fai a esci di
casa evitando no che i t rex diranno che
ti schiacci qualche Brontosauro correndo
più veloce di un Velociraptor Come fanno
le gazzelle nella savana E cosa fai
cerchi giocoliere e riprendi quello che
fa
VHS ve le ricordate bene quella
videocassetta l'ho frustata fino a
romperla ed è stata quella al mio corso
di giocoleria
gioco ieri che ho trovato il primo
esercizio che faceva Questo esercizio
Canonico facile che fanno tutti ci ho
messo una settimana per impararlo
problema il secondo esercizio che faceva
era questo è un problema perché questo
ho chiamato boxe è l'esercizio tra i più
complessi da imparare all'inizio
complesso Perché fai due lanci
contemporaneamente complesso perché una
pallina praticamente non la vedi E
allora cosa ho fatto io Federico che
volevo diventare giocoliere che incontro
uno scoglio
prima cosa
no troppo alto
no troppo basso
Bravo Riprova ti viene prova con l'altra
mano ora che ce l'hai impara a fare
questo ma visto che questo lo farai
insieme a questo impara a fare questo
senza guardare bene ora che ti viene
impara a fare due lanci una senza
guardare e ora che ti vengono metti
insieme le due cose No non era così era
due lanci due prese due lanci due prese
a destra sinistra a destra ora che ti
viene tutto metti insieme tutto stando
attento che c'è un ritmo un piano da
rispettare un angolo di lancio
Sapete cosa ho fatto
Ho applicato un metodo matematico a
qualcosa che matematica non era ho preso
un problema l'ho scomposto ho imparato i
singoli pezzi separatamente e poi messi
insieme con categorie il piano l'angolo
il ritmo che avevo chiaro in testa
vedete
se io cerco discipline la matematica per
esempio non le avesse applicate io non
potevo diventare giocoliere capite Ma
quando l'ho fatto Non mi sono reso conto
di quello che stavo facendo
la cultura lo sapete meglio di me è ciò
che rimane dopo che hai studiato e
dimenticato quello che si fa scuole
studiare un livello più alto per poi
dimenticare buona parte delle cose vi
rimangono competenze che puoi applicare
capito è un po' Come allenarsi a gravità
100 per combattere sulla Mac
Dragon Ball no e Come combattere con i
pesi ai polsi e le caviglie per
combattere contro gara No il torneo
Rocky Naruto No
è Come allenarsi occorre sulla sabbia
per giocare una partita di calcio
le Benji neanche è come legarsi catene e
polsi per imparare a fare il buger più
efficace come quella masochista di
miniaiuara no vabbè ok Le metafore non
sono il mio forte ma lasciamo stare
stiamo sul pezzo Federico se non avesse
studiato matematica fisica educazione
fisica sia io io la chiamo ancora
ginnastica come chiamo presti bidelle
ginnastica Se non avessi studiato
ginnastica io non avrei avuto la
coordinazione per fare cose di questo
tipo No è Importante sottolineare perché
io ho delle studentesse che
non fanno ginnastica si giustificano ma
non una volta al mese tutte le volte si
giustificano e poi non fanno neanche
sport e sono delle centropoltronare che
le vedi correre dove brufoli siamo dei
cinghialottiche Non può essere così
l'intelligenza va sviluppate prima che
ti servono È fondamentale Pensateci i
grandi scienziati hanno fatto le
scoperte fra i 20-30 anni Newton a 21
Einstein ha partorito la relatività
ristretta a 26 capite quindi deve essere
pronto Quando arriva quel momento aver
sviluppato l'intelligenza per essere
pronta ad affrontarle le cose vanno
fatte per tempo se non avessi studiato
matematica fisica educazione fisica
giocoliere non diventava e Voi direte
Vabbè facevi altro non ci conosciamo e
vi perdono ma a me fare questo
rende felice
fate finta di diventare grandi
di capire che avevate la possibilità di
diventare felice e perché non avete
studiato
con chi ve la prendete
è un problema eh Perché a quel punto te
la prendi con te Federico
avevo uno studente uno di quelli bravi
si diplomato con grandi voti si è
laureato molto bene È stata assunto da
Accenture a Milano e quando arriva lì
l'ha contattato la Google quella Google
passa il colloquio piace il suo
curriculum
non passa il colloquio in inglese Ora
lui che l'inglese non ha mai studiato
non interessava gli piaceva la
matematica con chi se la prende Ora lui
ha un problema enorme da gestire con se
stesso capite le cose vanno studiate
vanno approfondite vanno imparate prima
che ti servono metafora fate finta di
essere nella savana no E state
camminando e arriva un leone e no scusi
signor Leone devo imparare a correre e
poi scappo no o sai scappare o sai
correre o ti sbrana il cinghialotto no
l'esempio quello visto che ci sono
buttiamo dentro tutti un'altra
Studentessa che era una bravissima
violinista
questa ragazza prima lezione di
matematica in quella classe Alza la mano
prof a me della matematica cosa
interessa Io suono il violino
Ora lei che andava al conservatorio che
si diplomata sia il liceo che cosa
potevo rispondere
vedi
ha dimostrato che un violinista che sarà
la matematica è un violinista più bravo
di uno che non la sappia intendete non
stanno paragonando Bach e newtons shock
No è lo stesso violinista se conoscesse
anche la matematica sarebbe perché
dentro la musica c'è una marea di
matematica e le simmetrie le regolarità
no E quindi è questo che devi
approfondire capite e
vi hanno mai detto che siete stupidi
se capitasse la reazione è questa
quando si rialza e smette di sanguinare
a quel punto gli chiedi scusa ma in
quale delle 7 8 intelligenze perché
vedete esistono si pensa oggi 9
intelligenze diverse e queste
intelligenze tutte collaborano per farsi
diventare la cosa migliore in bullista
migliore che possiamo essere
Avevo un amico
all'università che in Matematica era un
mostro No non brutto Bravo vedete e
questo ragazzo crea una grande
intelligenza matematica 5/6
dimostrazioni diverse indipendenti non
capiva gli altri avevo l'intelligenza
interpersonale che non faceva battute
che spezzava il cuore alle persone senza
rendersi conto che e quindi per essere
una persona che vive la vita le diverse
intelligenze vanno sviluppate Anche
perché
si autoalimentano Sì sì
Naruto Scusatemi livello è quello mondo
Ninja diversi Chakra ognuno deve capire
qual è il suo Chakra No più importante
qual è l'intelligenza che funziona
meglio allora c'è il chakra fuoco quello
acqua quello vento ma mettendo insieme
Chakra diversi però anche se il tuo
forte è solo uno puoi creare qualcosa di
nuovo il chakra terre quello acqua danno
il chakra legno per esempio capite Ecco
l'idea Ecco cosa fare cercate di
sviluppare al massimo le nostre diverse
intelligenze studiando anche le materie
che a scuola non ci piacciono per
diventare cosa
cittadini
ci raccontano che la scuola deve
prepararci per il lavoro
Non è vero
ci stanno mentendo
la scuola che formare il cittadino dare
competenze che si basano su conoscenze
così che lui possa partecipare ad essere
così libero alla Gaber capite i mestieri
si imparano col tempo e poi cambiano
cambiano velocemente e mai velocemente
come oggi allora quelli verranno ma io
devo lavorare sulle basi per far cosa
ragazzino di 15 anni Federico di 15 anni
al dovere verso Federico di 20 di 30 di
40 di permettergli studiando di
diventare domani insegnante
divulgatore attore o diventare
giocoliere
[Musica]
ecco vedete
se noi lavoriamo su diverse intelligenze
se sviluppiamo veramente fino in fondo
se le approfondiamo e questo mettiamo
insieme le altre esperienze della vita
possiamo a quel punto
trovare quella famosa luce
alimentarla
e lasciarla brillare
Grazie
[Applauso]